ja leute wie erkläre ich euch dass sie
ist schon von mir alle anderen hat er
nicht gemacht
das kann man das ich machen die leute
hatten steigen gerade leute haben schon
noch nicht
der einzige frage ist eigentlich was von
deutschland nicht gemacht dieser
plattform bild.de ganz ehrlich von einer
halben stunde lang noch planlos in
meinem welt dafür so scheiße yahoo keine
idee was soll ich heute hochladen und
dann halbiert ritterlicher wer jetzt
abstimmen ich bin vor drei tagen druck
machen im komitee thema gefragt also
schalten trieb durch und sehe einfach
noch dran kommentiert morgen laufen
und dann dachte ich mir weißt du was
warum eigentlich nicht ich finde mich
leute auf youtube sollte jeder sein
eigenes ding macht nur ihr solltet den
content machen mit dem er sich selbst
wohl fühlt und ich muss sagen es klingt
seltsam aber ich habe richtig lust auf
dieses video
ich glaube das ist genau meine schiene
einfach irgendwie scheiße machen die
einfach total verrückt ist und
wahrscheinlich bei den total viele total
anstößt sie ankommt und wo für total
viel erheben werden also genau diese
scheiß irgendein merkwürdigen schild das
ist glaube ich genau mein leonie mehr
daran die motiviert ich gerade bin dass
ich richtig bock darauf habe ich habe
danach an einem underdog noch gefragt in
welcher struktur ich das video machen
sollte oder durch die themen sprechen
soll
und niemand hat mir geglaubt dass ich
einfach gerade das schreiben von einem
twitter-account allem einfach gedacht
irgendwann hat den twitter-account
übernommen ich habe geschrieben heute
max hat man account übernommen das ist
mein voller ernst oder alle so ja ja ja
ja ja beweisvideo dementsprechend sind
jetzt alle meine twitter follower zu
hause schockiert im denken sich so
besteht das macht er nicht es macht ja
nichts macht er nicht aber leute walking
nord auch im sinne des wortes ihr
müsstet video gar nicht so sinnlos laut
nicht alles können tatsächlich
irgendwann haben anders als baden im
griff schreibt wisst ihr was alle machen
worauf sie bock haben sie werde wehtun
und deswegen let's go mit dem kommentar
über morgen hatten youtube zentrum 16
kpd tweet aufgemacht wo ich euch gewalt
was ich hier mal wissen wollte und die
zwei leute die tatsächlich mich ernst
genommen haben dabei mir das zugetraut
haben die bekomme viele fragen
beantwortet denn erstmal eine allgemein
ist die pak in morgenland darf man so
was überhaupt mal den titel schreiben
weiter ich hätte mein video wird einfach
bis zum gehtnichtmehr age disstrack
bedeutet das wirklich
respekt mein gesamter kanal wird einfach
ohne vorwarnung gelöscht alter ich
schwöre euch wo bist du erst gehört bei
mir es wird passieren die leute wie das
video heute nicht sehen schon morgen auf
youtube und gucken was hat er gestern so
hochgeladen oder schon von iris ab und
an ist aber in meiner box links
dann schauen sie nach abheben
interessiert mich eigentlich schon was
er hochgeladen hat natürlich
unrealistisches szenario aber tun immer
so ist jemand interessiert dann bildet
in deutschland und denn wer meinen kanal
einfach gelöscht und der grund dafür
dieses kommentare die leute herzlich
willkommen zum letzten kommentare auf
meinem kanal und plötzlich aus dem
besten video weil wir nach einfach der
kanal vom youtube persönlich gelöscht
wird die youtube geschäftsführerin susan
wittchen
susan wolters wird persönlich die
management vornehmen einfach wird dieses
video sehen und wird sie aber denken und
dieses video das mit
aber fangen wir jetzt mal alle leute wir
wollen ja mit dem video auch eine
gewisse informations botschaft
übermitteln dementsprechend legen los
eher schon die frage zu klären warum
geht's okay die ist ein phänomen was
normalerweise wird nur bei männern
auftritt sollte es bei euch auftreten
obwohl eine frau seit ich das jetzt kein
weltuntergang aber vielleicht im
gewissen umfang grund zur besorgnis
ich hoffe einfach keine budget monate
etwas ihr gerade sage niemand aus meinem
sozialen umfeld von meiner uni oder so
sieht jeweils dieses video
das könnte zu ja es könnte sehr
seltsamen fragen für einen sehr
verwirrten fragen sollte motto du ja ich
finde das war ein youtube machst aber
was der leute sogar das passieren auf
jeden fall aber ich nichts erst mal auch
nicht weil wie gesagt irgendwas sagt mir
dass es lustig werden könnte
deswegen fangen wir an es ist ein
phänomen was wie der name schon sagt
morgens auftritt bei den vertretern des
männlichen geschlechts und es ist dass
er morgen ab
mathe ist quasi ein sprach dieses bild
ist eine analogie für die berühmte
holzlatte die sich besonders dadurch
auszeichnet dass sie ja aus holz ist und
damit aus einem festen material und ja
ich hab den rest muss hier in dieser
stelle auch nicht mehr erklären dieses
phänomen tritt in der regel morgens auch
weil sonst wäre es natürlich die
entsprechende abend hatten selbst endet
die kennen wir alle
dieses phänomen kann durchaus als lästig
empfunden werden würde ich sagen
und soweit einfach meine vorliebe gilt
hat mir auf eure zuschauer fragen ein
die mehr zu diesem thema gestellt hat
und zwar kannst du einen videowagen gibt
was warum bekommen wir eine morgen hatte
sagte er es geht werden sich auch die
habe keine fakten ammann ich will kein
arzt braucht keine medizinische bildung
geschweige denn überhaupt irgendeine
ahnung warum das passieren könnte
ich bin einfach nur leidtragenden dieses
phänomen dadurch daran beteiligt
dann weißt du mehr oder weniger vom es
geht die mädels ein bisschen weniger als
jungs precious fragt bekommt man im
ballhaus wird mit beweisvideo ob es die
da gibt jetzt ist die sache natürlich
leute ich nehme dieses video gerade um
18 uhr 30 auf bundes soll heute noch
kommen und die frage ist jetzt schaffen
wir es rechtzeitig zum bauhaus und
beweist wieder aufzunehmen ob es morgen
hatten im haus gibt
nein die antwort ist nein und eine
soziale küsse blickt jetzt like to
business manager
hey hallo und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge minecraft optik und
holte sprechende über die motto ich bin
gut dosiert durch ist erfahren im umgang
mit der morgenröte weiß wie das wetter
morgen nahm ich hätte steigen erfahrung
des japanischen yens alter besser
verlief es wird um 16
sie will wissen zum thema warum ich eine
videoüberwachte ja mein lieber sohn ich
das wurde einfach auf mein bett und
dachte mir okay was wird otto und
manchmal man keine anderen hoch
wegkommen aufseher abwegige gedanken und
dann kam eben diese schulter vorschlag
also es war ursprünglich nicht mal die
idee und ich dachte mir okay die idee
ist etwas ungewöhnliche manchmal können
es aber diese haben bis jetzt ging es
mit einer gerüstet das ist für die
astrophysik straßen in kiel wahr das
hab' ich clown arbeit t shirt prangt ein
taxi und ob ich okay next nach warum
bekomme ich seit monaten keine mehr muss
ich zum arzt
yanar live bekommt man die meisten
spender oder kanada dann kontrolliert es
ist die einzige ernsthafte frei oder
diese ganzen tweet und ich glaube ich
glaube ich versprechen wieder zeit
ehrlich gesagt ich meine der kommentar
von mir können jetzt zumindest mal die
richtigen würde das an sich selbst
wie ok leute es war ein sehr chaotisches
video ich hatte einfach lust einmal aus
scheiße dieses videos machen einfach aus
scheiße okay sagt sich informativ es war
uns konkurrieren aber vielleicht lustig
für euch diesem sinne schreibt einfach
mal feedback zu den verrückten die
kommentare und bis zum nächsten mal